consider the molecules represented above
and the data in the table below we have
the structure appeared for 19 a
structure for 2 3 4 tri fluoro pentane
which is really hard to say so I'm going
to abbreviate that PFP and we have the
Stata on the table so 9 & 2 3 4 tri
fluoro pentane have almost identical
molar masses so 128 versus 126 grams per
mole but nonane has a significantly
higher boiling point so we can see that
nonane has a boiling point of 151 verses
89 Celsius for our TFP which of the
following statements best helps explain
this observation before we look at our
answer choices let's think really fast
about what it means to have a higher or
lower boiling point the boiling point
tells us how much energy we have to add
to break the intermolecular bonds
between all of our molecules so a higher
boiling boiling point means that you
have more intermolecular forces to
overcome so what we're really asking
here is which of these answer choices
explains why nonane has more
intermolecular forces amongst the
molecules compared to TFP so answer
choice a says the carbon fluorine bond
is easier to break than the carbon
hydrogen bond and we know this is the
wrong answer because this has nothing to
do with intermolecular forces when
something boils you're not actually
breaking any of the covalent bonds so
that doesn't explain anything about the
boiling point answer choice B says that
the carbon fluorine bond is more polar
than the carbon hydrogen bond
so you can see that TFP does have these
carbon-fluorine bonds and we know that a
carbon hydrogen bond isn't all that
polar and fluorine is pretty
electronegative so this is true this
statement by itself is true so this is
true but does it explain the boiling
point trend and the answer there is it
actually doesn't so we're saying that if
the carbon fluorine bond is more polar
than these bonds here were saying that
if TFP has more polar bonds that would
normally suggest it has stronger
intermolecular forces which would mean
you would predict it to have a higher
boiling point and so that's the opposite
of what we're actually seeing here even
though our TFP has more polar CF bonds
it actually has a lower boiling point so
this observation which is true still
doesn't explain what we're trying to
trying to UM try and explain so choice c
says the carbon chains are longer in 19
than they are in 2 3 4 tri fluoro
pentane so if we just look at the
pictures here of the structures this is
also true in 19 we have these one two
three four five six seven eight nine
carbons we have nine carbons versus one
two three four five carbons so how could
we link this to the boiling point we
know that even though the molar mass
here is the same the length of the chain
is actually related to the London
dispersion forces
so as the length of the chain goes up
that actually means that the London
dispersion forces so the force the
intermolecular forces that happen when
you get these in tiny instantaneous
dipoles those forces also go up so we're
saying okay this has a longer chain
therefore it will have more London
dispersion forces because these
molecules are better able to interact
with each other with their instantaneous
dipoles and that means these forces go
up and the boiling point should go up
and that's what we're trying to explain
so C is the correct answer
but let's look at D anyway just to make
sure we didn't make any we didn't make
any bad decisions so just checking D
says the carbon chains are further apart
in a sample of nonane than they are in
two three four tri fluoro pentane well
we don't actually know if this is true
or not but let's see if if this
statement or true would it lead to the
boiling point trend or seeing if the
carbon chains are further apart in
nonane further apart would mean the
further apart they are the weaker the
intermolecular forces so this would mean
nonane has weaker intermolecular forces
and that would suggest it would have a
lower boiling point so a lower boiling
point and again this is not what we're
trying to explain we know it has a
higher boiling point so this also
doesn't explain that doesn't explain the
boiling points so the answer is C